good morning John what's that what's
that is the final first edition this is
actually the thing that will be in
stores version of my book and it's
pretty and it's beautiful and I love it
and it's terrifying John I've been
talking to a lot of press people lately
and they have so far invariably asked me
a question about whether there's a sense
of competition between you and me am I
going to compare the success of my book
to the success of your books is there
some element of me wanting to write a
book because like my older brother
didn't and I want to prove that I'm an
author too in fact on Tuesday I was
talking to a reporter from The Wall
Street Journal and when she got to this
section of her notes she sounded like
she was kind of begrudgingly asking me
this question like she knew what the
answer was gonna be and here here it is
it is never even occurred to me that my
book will sell as well as any of your
books and not because it's a ridiculous
idea which it is but because I don't I
don't imagine my success in relation to
your success why I've been thinking a
lot about success lately because there's
a lot of frustration and burnout in the
YouTube community I think and I'm in
thinking that we can often forget that
success is a different shape for
different people like we each imagined
it to be a different thing and it also
changes shape there have been times in
my life where I have changed the way
that I imagine the world and in those
moments the shape of success has changed
for me and sometimes those have been
hard moments but I think they've always
been good moments and one thing about a
success is that just like any shape you
can't see how big it is unless you put
it in relation to something else one of
the most common ways you do this is you
compare today's success with how you
were doing in the past but we also put
our success in relation to other
people's success or at least our
conception of their success and I think
that happens for reasons obvious and not
a lot with siblings but and I can't tell
you why it hasn't happened with us it's
not because we're not competitive like
put Hank and John Green on a mini golf
course and cross your fingers that
everybody comes out not bleeding I think
to some extent these videos got better
because we were trying to outdo each
other but not in a way that was like I
want to be more successful than you just
in a way that
I want to make a better joke than you
that's very different from like
measuring the value of our contributions
to the universe in relation to each
other which is kind of what this
artificial and now somewhat kind of
gross sounding concept of success really
means I honestly feel like every time
something good happens to you it's a
good thing happening to me that is a
gift and it's a gift that was given to
me I think at least in part by this
community and this project and it is a
really valuable gift I'm very thankful
for it that reporter from The Wall
Street Journal also asked me if you were
planning any projects or anything like
that to promote the book and I told her
that I didn't I didn't know but like
probably was my guest but what I didn't
expect is this or any of this John thank
you so much thank you for being the
absolute model like the Platonic ideal
of what a supportive older brother can
be thank you for your support not just
now but for my whole life and your
support of this thing that I made which
is hard and weird and different and and
I'm really excited for it to be in the
world John I'll see you on Tuesday and
then not long after that in New York
City for the release of my book on
September 25th and the start of our tour
whoo endscreen there will be a book tour
September 25th in New York than Boston
Canton Ohio Chicago Kansas City Missouri
Indianapolis Milwaukee Denver Los
Angeles San Diego Santa Cruz and
Bellingham Washington also check out the
new nerdfighter backpack limited
supplies available now at dftba.com